they haven't seen or experienced a
cyclone in makuu Mia before yet this
isolated town in northern Mozambique
found itself in the eye of the storm and
it sliced through the community like a
knife I've never heard or seen anything
like it she said this was a welcome
sight for the town's residents who
haven't had a proper meal in a week bags
of rice and beans provided by the
British government although there wasn't
enough to go around
[Music]
anticipation gave way to arguments and
scuttles as everyone tried to claim
their share organising 20 packages for
27 families and they don't want to be
organised for a mother of six called
Celestine iya the lack of food was only
one of her worries a tree fell on my
house and I lost everything everything
plates food beds nothing's left granted
a half pail of beans she decided to walk
back home although there wasn't really
anything left of it the house had been
demolished by a giant tree I could take
her through things and try to make a new
room but look everything is damaged it's
very difficult
we found the president of Mozambique up
the road along with his cabinet telling
local people he tried to get things
fixed
how is Mozambique faring after these
these two natural disasters in six weeks
well it's it's relative
but for us you know that's you know
nobody is not always prepared to to be
with these kind of programs we are
trying to do our best
the storm has torn this community apart
and the people who run the nation are
struggling to cope John sparks Sky News
in makuu Mia